und wir haben einfach nur einmal ihn
gefragt ob er den aktuell weiß wie viele
Ukrainer im Moment Hartz IV Leistung
beziehen wie viel Flüchtlinge insgesamt
wie viel Ausländer Hartz IV Leistungen
in Deutschland beziehen wie hoch also
ist der Anteil und dann passierte in der
Sendung genau das
wie groß ist der Anteil an Ausländern
bei Hartz IV wissen sie das
ne ich weiß das nicht aber ich vermute
schon das ist eine erheblichen Anteil
gibt und dass ich jedenfalls da eine
Menge mehr tun können um
20% keine Ahnung
vielleicht 20%, das sind tatsächlich
es sind tatsächlich mittlerweile 45%
mein Thema jetzt mal das ist mein Thema
weil sie sagen zu war noch nicht
Sozialsysteme entschuldigung das ist
wirklich jemand die Sozialsysteme zu
Nikola Idee ist dann wurde sehr
emotional in dieser Sendung obwohl wir
eigentlich nur über die Zahlen
gestritten haben dass deutet darauf hin
dass es tabuisiert wird in Deutschland
ja und ich finde auch wir sind auch so
ein bisschen auf eine schiefe Ebene
geraten gerade mit ihrem Vortrag Frau
Zimmermann wo ist nur darum geht diese
Sache jetzt sozusagen zu verarbeiten in
Deutschland alles unterzubringen was an
jeden unterzubringen der ankommt und
un- und es zu schaffen auf deutsch
gesagt ich war aber das ist nicht allein
die Aufgabe sie hatten schon als
Regierung die Aufgabe meine ich auch
sich um die illegale Generation etwas
mehr zu kümmern weil das nämlich oben
drauf kommt wir können gerne sagen
Ukraine Flucht und da haben sie mich ein
bisschen unterbrochen das ist durchaus
legitim ja es gibt auch dort Anreize
aber ist die Anreise wirken viel stärker
natürlich auf die illegale Migration die
seit sieben Jahren jetzt doch nach
Deutschland kommt
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen gesprochen und
sie haben dann die Frage der
Sozialsysteme Einwanderung also diesen
pull-effekt war gar nicht
genau ich war gar nicht fertig das hatte
ich aber auch schon gesagt dass wir das
bitte nennen das haben sie überhört doch
schon aber das ist jetzt sehr sehr
wach sprechen durch besonders vor allen
Dingen wenn man von dem eigentlichen
Thema ablenkt sondern sie haben gerade
gesagt Ukraine pulleffekt und da habe
ich gesagt an diesem Punkt
definitiv sage und keinem ukrainischen
Flüchtling der gerade vor Bomben und
Terror flieht deswegen zu kommen um in
der Sozialsystem zu ziehen sich der
anderen Diskussion ja der Welt geht
sprechen über Einwanderung in die
Sozialsysteme sie nehmen die Ukraine
dort ausdrücklich aus und sprechen über
diejenigen die auf der Balkanroute sind
der Knaus wie groß sind die Zahlen der
aktuell wenn wir ich ich mache es ganz
konkrete Beispiel Baden-Württemberg da
kann ich die Zahlen nicht vor kurzem
wieder angesehen von den von 11
Flüchtlingen die Leute mir aufgenommen
in diesem Jahr aufgenommen wurden sind
10 Ukraine wir haben was die Asylanträge
betrifft sind wir überhaupt nicht
vergleichbar mit 2015 damals kamen in 12
Monaten 2017
die ganzen 14 da hatten wir diese Zahlen
ja Heimatland schlägt aktueller Alarm
auch wegen der Zahlen von der
Balkanroute und Österreich Herr Ramsauer
hat das schon geschildert winkt im
Moment weitestgehend durch nach
Deutschland auf die 200.000 kommen Herr
Knaus das wissen auch sie ja also noch
einmal wir haben im Jahr 2015 in 12
Monaten eine Million Menschen gehabt die
aus der Türkei über das Meer nach
Griechenland kamen wir haben in diesem
Jahr bekannt 12.000 das ist was wir
derzeit erleben ist keine große neue
irreguläre Migration in die Europäische
Union weil wir haben machen
ist das in Griechenland Menschen so
behandelt werden dass sogar anerkannte
Flüchtlinge und zwar 40.000 anerkannte
Flüchtlinge vertrieben werden weil sie
dort nicht leben können nach Deutschland
kommen einen Antrag stellen und die
deutschen verwaltungsgerichtete
der deutschen verwaltungsgerichtet
übrigens ganz viele europäischen Ländern
es gibt keine Rückführung nach
Griechenland
weil die Menschenwürde der Menschen dort
aufgrund der Verletzungen der
europäischen Standards in Griechenland
nicht garantiert sind das bedeutet dass
eine kleine Zahl von Ländern Österreich
zählt dazu Griechenland Österreich die
Schweiz 22.000 Asylanträge pro Kopf
dieses Jahr mehr ist also er Klaus sagt
die Zahlen sind klein das sind
diejenigen die bisher in der
Griechenland untergebracht sind das ist
kein Migration aus Griechenland
die großen migrationstürmer einfach
schweigen
da wachsen die Flüchtlinge nicht auf den
Bäumen die müssen in den Westen
ist gekommen
Entschuldigung wo wir gerade sprechen
die kommen aus der Türkei nach
Griechenland nach Bulgarien und gehen
dann auf den balkanal
sind so immer
zu Hause
bleiben kann
auch Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme
das kommt nämlich aktuell von ihrem
Fraktionschef von Friedrich Merz wen
meint er damit
der meinte natürlich nicht nur
ukrainische Flüchtlinge die sich
angezogen fühlen natürlich durch das was
sie vorhin gesagt haben
aber trotzdem nochmal Frau Zimmermann
das allein ist natürlich kein
Fluchtgrund will das noch mal
klarstellen
weil sie mich vorhin so interpretiert
haben aber wir haben auf der Balkanroute
natürlich große Stauräume anders wäre es
nicht zu erklären dass Österreich haben
ich bin ja mit meinem Wahlkreis halber
Österreicher und da geht alles so
ineinander ich habe allein in meinem
Wahlkreis ungefähr 20 Grenzübergänge die
kann man überhaupt nicht kontrollieren
was glauben Sie was da reinkommt also
die sind nicht alle mit Autos befahrbar
sondern bequem mit
Fahrrad und zu Fuß und mit Rucksack und
also das da geht viel rüber klar also
jeder der nach Deutschland möchte
bei meinen Punkt
aber jeder der nach Deutschland möchte
kommt nach Deutschland es wird immer
irgendwer schreibt aber natürlich die
Innenministerin hat auch mit der
Bundespolizei die Grenzkontrollen jetzt
verstärkt in Absprache mit Österreich
mit Tschechien da wird auch einiges
getan
nach Deutschland kommen
Diskussion weil was machen wir uns
eigentlich vor was noch auf uns zukommt
wenn man sich mal die Situation auf der
Welt anguckt wir reden hier über die
Ukraine wir reden über den Balkan was
eigentlich im Nahen Osten kostenlos
im Irak im Syrien zwischen 50 und 70
Grad weitere Regionen dieses Landes in
diesem Sommer das heißt sie sind
unbewohnbare Länder das heißt die Rechte
werden viel viel viel größer so wie so
wie Norwegen Italien Schweden wird sich
Deutschland in den nächsten Jahren damit
auseinandersetzen müssen dass wir ganz
andere Migrationsfragen haben in anderen
Größenordnung das ist ein und die Frage
des Einwanderungslandes zu welchen
Politiker
Dimensionen gehen müssen dass wir jetzt
dass wir jetzt in dieser Situation
Menschen die vor unserer Haustür Leben
aufnehmen auch wenn es für uns hart ist
finde ich nach wie vor eine
Selbstverständlichkeit
in Frankreich sind oder haben wir
diskutiert
deswegen hier und Sie werden auch weiter
hierher kommen weil sie in nächster Nähe
zu ihrer Heimat
ein sicheren Ort suchen um aber weiter
Kontakt zu halten zu ihrer Heimat und
das ist keine Reisetätigkeit im Sinne
von Urlaub wenn Sie mit dem flixbus
zurückfahren sondern sie gucken ob Ihr
Haus noch steht ob ihr Vater noch lebt
und das ist normal
Selbstverständlichkeit